here's how you can make crazy claims in
your marketing and still be compliant
have them be true what that means is you
survey your customers on a continuous
basis and you survey their stats based
on whatever it is the thing that you
promise so whether it's weight loss
whether it's business whether it's
marketing and leads whatever and then
rather than say look at Andrea she did
ten thousand dollars in ten days instead
you Market using just the data of what
has happened if you look at Harvard they
just publish the stats of what the
graduation rate is what the average
salary is going out of Harvard and what
percentage of people actually land a job
within six months of graduation there's
no claim there they're just like this is
what it is and so if you shift your
marketing from this is what could happen
to this is what does happen that's where
you make the shift from being scammy to
being legitimate